you
galen the stud secretary of the
norwegian nobel committee thank you very
much for talking about the 2009 nobel
peace prize with us my pleasure I think
I described the response the
announcement that Barack Obama was
receiving the 2009 nobel peace prize as
a collective sharp intake of breath was
was that the sort of reaction you were
expecting well we've had many reactions
we have had much approval many like this
decision many were surprised and and
we'll see how this adds up as we have
time to gather reactions from all over
the world but it's a wonderful situation
to be to be in I mean reactions pour in
from the entire world it certainly has
and President Obama is someone who needs
no introduction but could you possibly
summarize why you decided to vote in the
2009 nobel peace prize we actually feel
that we are paying very close attention
to Annabel's will Nobel mentions that
this should be for achievement in the
preceding year and this indeed is sin
for achievements in the preceding years
and he mentions three criteria
fraternity between nations I mean Obama
has done an awful lot for fraternity
between nations reduction in standing
armies he has produced the division of a
nuclear-free world and and we are
expecting very substantial arms control
agreements and the holding of peace
Congress's the modern version of course
is international diplomacy so we feel
that this decision is very closely based
on alfred nobel's will and so can you go
into some more details about what you
think that the president obama has done
for these important contributions to
peace as you've just described well we
feel that he has basically produced a
new international climate the emphasis
is again on the UN and multilateral
institutions the emphasis is on dialogue
and negotiations the emphasis is in arms
control and disarmament the zero option
the emphasis is on a new climate
agreement with the
States being a very important partner
and the emphasis is on democracy and
human rights so he has produced a an
entirely new international climate and
so you can stress the word emphasis that
would have been the the concrete
achievements have been made well first
of all changing the international
climate and setting a new international
order is a concrete achievement and we
feel that these ideals which is the
primary spokesman of these are the
ideals of the Norwegian and Nobel
Committee and we have been trying to
support these ideals for 108 years and
when Obama then comes along and we have
this wonderful spokesman for these
ideals we feel he has achieved something
by changing the tone and the climate and
we want to give him whatever support you
can get in in producing concrete results
based on these ideals and President
Obama has been in office for less than
nine months has the Peace Prize ever
been awarded to a leader of a country
that's been so early in their term of
office well first of all we are actually
paying very close attention to Annabel's
well because he mentions the preceding
here and this is almost impossible for
most prices but this year it has been
possible there have been similar
examples I mean Oscar Arias for instance
when he produced a piece Banford for the
for Central America yeah he did receive
the price in the very same year I mean
just a few months after the peace plan
had been produced so so this is not
without precedent but Obama is a very
special person in his own right and you
know he's clearly someone who's making
inroads into the political process and
political climate as you described is
there any concern that awarding the
prize to President Obama so early on
into his term is going to push quite
high expectations onto someone who's
already under high expectations both
internationally and domestically
yes of course I mean we have gone over
these arguments they are they are very
obvious I think we all recognize the the
strong arguments in Obama's favor and
there are the obvious counter arguments
that we should wait but then he comes
along he presents this wonderful agenda
and we feel that we we should support
him but we have we have been over these
arguments many many times obviously and
and of course he can do all kinds of
things in his remaining term in office
but we always stand by our laureates i
mean he he should not be afraid that's
certainly one day he will do something
anyway and then a welcoming committee
will come out and denounce him we never
do we never denounce our laureates we
always stand by them and you've
mentioned all these peaceful efforts so
far but one thing that's been noticed of
course is that president obama's leader
of a country that's currently at war
with two countries and that's something
that people have been criticizing openly
how do you respond to those criticisms
of course a superpower like the united
states is bound to be involved in all
kinds of comp complex situations we are
not telling him that he should do this
or that in these concrete situations
whether we're talking about Afghanistan
or Pakistan but we are pointing to the
importance of the overall principles
which he stands for and I'm sure that
these principles are also relevant for
the situations in these countries and
then we'll see what he comes up with so
with all that slightly complex issues in
mind is there a specific message that
the Peace Prize Committee wants to
transmit by of orden de SPEs prize to
President Obama well the message in a
deeper sense is what I said that he he
follows very strongly the ideals of the
Norwegian Nobel Committee threw 108
years so we give him this for what he
has done
we give him this to encourage him to
continue his very important work along
these lines they will indulge lee be
failures and not only successes but in
this is in the nature of business for
any American president you mention
encouragement there so is that is there
any hope for what this Peace Prize can
achieve well we hope it it can influence
the world in his direction we have
rather realistic expectations we do not
think the nobel peace prize is a magic
wand it cannot transform the world but
maybe it can represent some sort of
encouragement and can bring added
support to his cause and finally have
you hadn't managed to get a chance to
speak to president obama and not yet we
are working on it but we have had a
preliminary reaction from him and he's
very grateful for what has been done
okay let's start thank you very much for
discussing this with us thank you
you